[Musique]
la vie c'est comme une boîte de
chocolats on sait jamais sur quoi on va
tomber c'est un peu comme le grand mythe
ya des hauts et il ya des morts il ya
des moments là où c'est à vous qui allez
maintenant gros et il ya des moments
borgo lorsque je vais vous demander
c'est cet après midi avec nous c'est de
célébrer tous ensemble les moments
positifs de notre vie parce que c'est lé
moment vous qui nous font oublier les
moments bof bof
cet après midi chez de présenter trois
clés trois pelés qui ont positivement
influencer baby 9 juin 2008
je suis au milieu de ma vie mais j'en ai
fait le tour
je suis coach consultante en
négociations internationales
j'ai dû faire cinq fois le tour du monde
en quinze ans mais j'en ai fait le tour
j'ai besoin d'air et là je surf sur
internet et je tombe sur un article 5
personnes un petit groupe viennent de
fonder en france une association de
conférences il professionnels
conférencier professionnel qu'est ce que
ça veut dire ce métier moi je parlais
déjà je parlais à des petits groupes
je pousse chez des personnes par petits
groupes et des formations de 10 12
personnes mais c'est quoi un
conférencier
et bien conférencier professionnelle et
payée de paris waouh je me dis ça c'est
un élément voit le soir même le document
parce qu'ils s'apprêtent à partir à new
york
big apple dans un mois et demi ils
seront tous à new york pour célébrer la
convention annuelle des conférenciers
pro sociale et là mon sang ne fait qu'un
tour
je me dis ça c'est pour moi j'me voyais
déjà là je me voyais déjà y être et le
soir même ce que je devais quand même
pour vaincre conjoint c'est soir mans et
les enfants n'étaient plus un avec nous
en vacances donc c'était l'idéal pour
les avoir avec nous en vacances le
redirai au vin à new york
ils avaient respectivement 18 ans et 20
ans et ça faisait déjà belle lurette a
donc qu'il aurait pu partir de papa
maman et dieu ou le soir même on avait
deux billets pour partir ailleurs
et ça c'est un moment que vous n'êtes
pas la violence
c'est génial on part à new york et on se
retrouve le 2 août 2008 à times square
times square la convention la convention
internationale des orateurs
professionnelle et la curieuse comme je
suis je passe la verite noir et une fois
le sol voyez le fun à peu près 10 fois
comme ce soit à l'isf comme ça tu
applaudis
des rangées de chaînes une scène et 50
mètres d'envergure et dix dates de
profondes et là elle est vide
regardez comment il est quand elle est
remplie et des écrans partout et là qui
suit au 1er mai je suis assis tout
devant avec mon équipe la preuve
je représente dignement la france parce
que pour les français être conférence
est trop vrai qu'on n'est pas forcément
brillant de domaine de la prise de
parole en france
je suis ravi qu'on organise un thé dax
qui des taxes en passe maintenant c'est
fabuleux
je suis assis au premier rang je suis
assis à côté d'un monsieur qui va
compter beaucoup pour moi il fallait
d'un moteur et je suis assise à côté
nous et je suis comme le loup dantec
sabrina n'était gelabale qui soit je
vois c'est orateur exceptionnel
déambuler sur cette scène gigantesque et
dans l'après midi ils reçoivent un prix
csp socrates bidule qui fâchent mais
hélas juste que les américains appellent
wahou facture salée waouh le trip qui
comprend l'un qui peuvent par l'homme
elop de monde je me dise pas oui si pour
certaines moins à 6h de fête et tables
vois mon et moyens dit la petite
frenchie la fox forte comme ils nous
appellent et en train de s'émouvoir la
même table comme ça sur la côte est dit
what's up
qu'est ce qui se passe et je lui dis je
serai dan la première personne va voir
le système france et light of the world
yauque nem
know i'm not a calé j'ai 45 ans et ça
c'est un moment de ce village rencontre
laisse plein lors tous ceux qui
connaissent les blancs y en a qui
connaissent les bandes dans la salle
alors allez voir tifel les parents c'est
un des plus inspirants conférencier au
monde il a une voix tonitruante
il parle avec ses tripes je partais de
seyfried cher américains sont pas
reconnus en france et il m'a spi et ils
passent billets parce qu'il prononce une
phrase énorme
on est jamais trop vieux pour se fixer
un nouveau but pour rêver d'un nouveau
rêve
répétez après moi je suis jamais trop
vieux pour me faire de vos buts et pour
avoir mon de vos rêves
mais bien sûr et safari jeune homme dans
ma tête ça présente dans mon ventre et
là je me dis que le premier point le
premier point la première règle est que
je partageais avec des marges et s'ils
se visualiser se visualiser la situation
des sites parce que vous savez comment
on fonctionne tous général vers 4 5
heures du matin quand on a me stresse
ans yanakis a pas besoin
le tibet lotissement large va nous
arriver qu'elle marchera jamais eh bien
le truc nous premier truc première clé
qui a largement influencé ma vie c'est
de se projeter de visualiser en
situation de réussite
et voilà comment je me suis je me suis
vu comme ça c'était mon rêve je me suis
vu vraiment dans cette posture
j'avais saisi mon pourquoi pourquoi je
voulais faire ça je voulais faire ça
pour partager avec le monde pour y mener
le monde des idées que j'avais du
partage
je suis professionnel de l' influence
j'ai navigué dans le monde entier j'ai
accompagné d'étape chef d'entreprise une
négociation internationale en technique
d'un flux ans mais je me faisais des
petits groupes ce que je voulais moi
c'était influencé monde entier
d'animosité quand vous trouvez les
pourquoi votre pourquoi est assez grand
et 16 de 10 élèves blancs qui m'a
tellement inspiré
alors vous allez trouver votre chemin
c'est plus du tout un problème de
trouver comment faire lorsqu'on a
identifié pour religieuse deuxième pire
deuxième clé extraordinairement
importante pour réussi à réaliser les
traits de scies avoir un cap
alors toutes voiles dehors toutes voiles
dehors le câble le voilier belles images
le navigateur doit avoir un cap sinon
surtout si vos parents
tap - le cap c'était le csp certified
speaking visage non c'est toi le csp ça
veut dire quoi concrètement
le csp c'est sur cinq ans à voir les
vingt conférences payante minimum chaque
année pour 625 dollars de chiffre
d'affaires minimum en conférence pour 25
clients différents ensuite il vous faut
trop de chrétiens éducatif à la vérité
rend les cartons clients parce qu'il
fonda vivait chez eux payer à chaque
fois et mais en même temps vous êtes
remis à l'occasion de la convention
internationale les conventions
internationales y en a eu un paquet qui
convient et 1020 lettre de
recommandation sur papier en tête et là
on sait qu en france c'est pas du tout
dans l'état d'esprit des français
les premiers monde a appelé vous deviez
vous seriez d'accord de dire vous êtes
fronton boulot à soupapes d'un des deux
ter et ensuite ils reçoivent athés
tionale il doit ne pas tout après
confidentielles et il donne note
il y pas mignon cet ennemi se disent ils
à gros mot et oui c'est contre voie d
oise participe au laos
mais là le pourquoi c'est comment faire
rêver et l' autre chose résonne en moi
toujours d'une citation est un qui dit
n'a pas besoin d'être exceptionnelle
pour commencer mais pour tu commences
pour être exceptionnel et c'est ce que
je faisais ça commence par le cap de
bonne espérance en afrique du sud est
assez marquée par i9100 propre écurie
match quand je commence donc à faire ou
tout du moins pour gagner les éléments
qui vont permettre d'atteindre le sésame
de la grèce du confort en six pôles et
là on voit dans pleins pleins d'endroits
de plein de conventions internationales
j'ai tout fait j'ai fait mon gros pari
l'espagne l'allemagne la hollande
j'ai rencontré des tas de gens
extrêmement influente et puis j'ai
commencé dans des toutes petites salles
j'ai commencé à parler des toutes
petites salles et bien bonheur de
pouvoir inspirer des toutes petites
salles pour elle toute petite salle qui
fait entre 100 et 200 personnes et les
grandes salles cette vallée des ombres à
6500 personnes dont six visuels et
c'était extraordinaire commence et qui
caractérise grand orateur il disait tu
veux poser
abba cause va peser dans ton quartier va
poser dans les maisons de retraite va
causer dans les associations de chefs
d'entreprises va poser aux retards et
aux lions ce club à cause des petits de
parler par et un jour tout est ce que tu
peux gagner ta vie en étant conférences
et brouillent pour payer pour parler
donc là une conférence dans une beaucoup
plus grande salle dans une grotte vous
n'êtes pas c'est la faute aux
psychiatres ont un nom comme cette photo
c'était brotchi rentrée la tranche petit
pois chiches huis clos seront donc
c'était dur pour moi d'aller dans dans
cette grotte alors 3e pelé s'entourer
des meilleurs chanteurs et des meilleurs
et là j'ai dû faire des choix j'ai dû
faire un choix pour représenter la
demande meilleure autour de moi
le premier meilleur c'est méchant
méchant c'est quelqu'un qui a pas eu
beaucoup
hall dont il a une trentaine d'années il
s'est crashé avec sa moto sous un câble
qui a explosé était sorti brûlé à 70%
surtout pour les huiles ya un message il
dit 6 passes du tarif de la vie car si
spotify et sur le plan professionnel m'a
appris quelque chose de magique c'est le
roi de la pop aux médecins nous pose
c'est comme le montrent à sheffield
scène il faut du temps au sabre ou
pomelos ou passer à travers les mots qui
semblent s'estomper challenge qui
l'emploie qui vient avec lui dois mon
sens pas bien il est toujours entouré
des plus banals faits et j'en ai pu le
constater un autre mentor un vrai
battant quelqu'un qui a compté
énormément pour moi pour obtenir ce csp
ces hormones rennais sont allés voir ce
qu'il fasse pareil c'est quelqu'un qui a
publié péri à celle de marketing 25
millions de vies qu'un
25 millions d'euros et bim après un truc
qu'on va te l'a coaché pendant deux ans
toutes les semaines le mercredi soir de
17h à 18h quitté ce matin pendant
presque deux heures jusqu'à ce que
j'obtienne de l'association et 8 après
un toc extra que je partage à lui il m'a
dit tu sais quoi sur scène la plupart
des orateurs
il souffre d'un syndrome quelque chose
de vraiment nul la première fois que la
dynamique ça s'appelle le syndrome
direction oui c'est ça du tout c'est les
os apple ça des pions l'étude coller aux
omoplates comédie l'accident en fait le
dis tu as alten déjà il te connaissent
pas mais tu aimes déjà donc embrasse
nasa
les différences entre sexes laura sa
femme ça change tout ça c'est évident
troisième mentor qui a vraiment pour
projet s'est ravisé en pur est
fonctionnel
c'est le spécialiste des techniques de
vente sur internet entre autres il a
plus d'un million d'abonnés sur sa
chaque jour c'est lui qui m'a appris à
faire des vidéos inspirant ceux qui sont
curieux sur les voir un peu sur internet
ils peuvent voir des vidéos gratuites
les 6es c'est sympa et franck younès
c'est quelqu'un qui va après ne sait
quelque chose de majeur
il m'a appris c'est important d'avoir
une marque exactement top1 marques
célèbres de fromage wade ou saks on
achète ce fromage la passe qui a marqué
sa dessus et bien pour un orateur
provient de choses et marque ses
spécialistes leur influence positive 8
700 spectacles jean 6h indice et lui ont
comme ça et propriétaires de ces trois
mots clés sur internet donc toutes les
personnes qui celles qui cherchent
techniques de vente
le king et ça c'est un actionnaire
important d'ailleurs le conférencier il
impose sa voix bien posée mais si c'est
pas vendre ce qu'ils disent impliqués
pour donc voilà ce qu'a appris francs et
puis dan dan porteur celui auquel je
faisais référence au début
de mon discours talent qui a énormément
compté pour moi qui m'appelle toujours
mal est fait et qu'ils disent a b i walk
et des nomades et lui il a quelque chose
qui m'a beaucoup inspiré aussi ils
disent au pacte humeur avec un livre
photo est aujourd'hui mopelex de roanne
j'ai le plaisir et la joie de vous
annoncer que depuis le 5 mai nous avons
la confirmation que le prochain rives
le premier pour moi pas être édité chez
un énorme éditeurs de livres
professionnels en france ça c'est
vraiment un moment là du coup et
véronique qui était l'amante amener ou
pis y en a quelques-uns qui sont revenus
et bien véronique ses deux
collaboratrices mme brad wall qui je
travaille depuis six ans et la b
derrière j'étais gravement malade
si talent qui va remplacer au pied levé
un mois avant l'été dit ce droit l'an
dernier j'ai été diagnostiqué avec cinq
tueurs ont agressif tant pis pour les
hommes c'est compliqué des profits on
sert d'un v6 et aux toilettes
les nominés dont je peux pas vraiment
être la rupture en 06 et véronique c'est
mon coeur c'est ma fidèle collaboratrice
et aldrin et avait un roi se disant
social un autre clin d'oeil que je vais
pas parce que ça aussi c'est une
personne qui m'a énormément apporté
c'est fred frédéric château grâce à
cette femme qui dit non du spécialiste
et qui pose des anneaux gastriques
virtuel ici tel que vous ne voyez vous
avez vu sur les photos j'ai un peu plus
d'an comprend j'ai perdu en un an
inquiet je voulais lui rendre hommage ou
starcraft i des grandes personnes de ma
vie je vais vraiment partagé aujourd'hui
15 juillet 2010
[Applaudissements]
venez donc j'estime les esprits ça fait
un moment et oui c'est ce que j'ai
entendu et juste deux pays partagent
depuis daniel pauly speaker qui sont là
et quand j'ai entendu gueuler je l'avais
dit attendre une heure après d'âpres
dans ses bons jours jeudi à tambour
l'est c'est comme chevrolet du coup
c'est plus aucun problème pour eux
prononcés au fait il maintenant
chevrolet ce facile pour eux
voilà laurent qui va me lui le sésame le
rasta qui était la présidente de la nasa
l'anticorps associé chez en 2012 voilà
le groupe américain donc la classe 2012
et csp y avait 22 août rejeté la 23e mon
équipe mon conjoint didier que vous
voyez les démolit fidèle à mes côtés un
climat en six ans aujourd'hui mon rêve
il est double c'est de transmettre la
passion du métier
à vous aussi à toutes les personnes qui
ont un message à faire passer
qui vont vite faire porter leur coeur au
monde qui ont envie de le partager qui
ont envie d'être dans des grandes salles
comme ça pour influencer les troupes le
monde entier et ça c'est des moments
c'est pas bien ça c'est des moments et
des moments où c'est clair et pour vous
que j'aimerais vous résumer c'est que
pour atteindre notre v12 mais vous y
visualiser en situation des sites vous
devez 1,24 et de conserver vous devez
savoir vous entonnez des médias et
surtout à vous quel est votre rôle
comment vous projetez vous comment vous
visualisez en situation de décider quel
est votre cas et avez vous identifié les
baigneurs
parce que si vous aidez les ont réalisé
leur rêve d'atteindre lé monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]